si vous qui ce fait les matches entre
communautés pouces bleus sûr sur youtube
une fessée quatre gars moi sa jumelle
puis en bessin boom le portugal en sueur
le brésil en sueur c'est cristiano
ronaldo le pion bessin accord y ait des
gens sûrs et ce que je le prends est ce
que je le prends pas il se passe quoi
cristiano et krikor il a eu peur il est
pas venu du bout des 5 il n'a pas pris
le pion il n'a pas pris le pion il s'est
fait dans le caleçon il s'est fait dans
le caleçon le portugais ou et brésilien
brasil samba il a eu peur et c'est la
vérité des amis gfr g3 fou g7
il s'est fait dans le caleçon et julhes
l'option b 5 salma sueur moi j'ai
peut-être pas le laisser très longtemps
et au bout d'un moment je vais prendre
il ne prend pas il a peur dim
eh bien il fallait le prendre un tonton
bim fois six miles en sueur l' issue
allez faire de fax et un saut s'est
battu pour à jouer le deuxième match
fade de fab allez on est bien voilà des
gens qui militent avance dans le chatt
allez on est tous bien là on est tous
bien on leur marche dessus
il s'est hissé j'ai envie de vous dire
hisser les gens ont besoin de moi je
l'en pls christian-roy - cristiano là il
sait plus où il habite un on est bon il
va me faire que trois jeux lui faire des
cinq et on nous écrit bonnes chances
face comme portugal mais bien sûr krikor
mais nous on te souhaite pas bonne
chance on espère que tu perdes tu es nul
tu vas perdre on n'est pas fair play on
n'est pas fair-play est ici krikor on te
fait le chat c'est pas parce que tu
joues avec nombreux chelsea qu'on va te
caresser dans le poêle fait très
attention
on n'a qu'une envie c'est gagner on est
là allez on a fait semblant d'être
gentil dont le chat pendant qui est venu
souhaiter bonne chance mais on espère on
on n'en pense pas moins
on n'en pense pas moins les amis on est
super chaud on l'a mis le plus en dessin
qu'on l'a mis en sueur cristiano renault
tire répertoire facile mais bien sûr ono
ça gagne elle répertorie l'eau facile
est ménagé une seule envie c'est lui
nuire mais bien sûr on a un objectif lui
nuire je tente
oui ça marche pas du tout et peut-être
damas quatre la question mais c'est pas
grave il fait payer 3000 ans issus l'
issue totalement cavaliers à cinq
cavaliers b3 ok ces quatre là on est en
train de rentrer à on est en train de le
pénétrer le produit y est on peut naître
du portugais là j'aime être le plus
grand c'est 6 pour le moment je veux
m'assurer le coup sort de bien blindé et
après on va y aller selon qui ces noms
comme valence allez on y va on y va les
amis on est bien là on est bien bim bim
lp au nez à l'espagnol à covina espagne
ainsi qu'au rial hébert coude a dit
periko comme le jambon attention on fait
très attention les amis on est bien les
amis on appris le pion et 2 cristiano en
sueur cristiano en sueur
sur place sont fous j'ai peur un peu sur
cahill c4 qui me prennent je prends il
fait cavalier 5 et le carillon 17 et qui
a eu 16 c'est peut-être damas quatre
bons c'est peut-être pourrions-nous da
pour réfléchir moi je fais un truc que
j'aime pas trop marqué ces quatre ça ça
cavaillé 5-fu b3 dame bouger x 4 j'aime
pas
peut-être mais bon j'aime pas trop ce
pion ces six là il va y vas t'y vas être
vulnérable j'aime pas trop les amis
comme en 2002 peu les sanctions comme ça
de mon switch oui je sais pas il est nul
pour ça qu'il est 2002 is who is who is
who qui titille is who is who is who is
who is who is who is who is who is who
is who geek qui nous guide leïla la
rater le coche pour la partie de 15h mai
de 18h mais il sera là pour la suivante
mais bien sûr on sera de plus en plus
nombreux les amis pour leur marché
dessous par contre est en train de
regarder les scores on se fait défoncer
ya déjà trois ans pour eux je met le
score a pris à trois là on est mal les
mecs à 3 1 pour il ya 3 1 pour eux et
nicobar en caux qui marque sa partie
bull nico arrivé c'était là un point
qu'on avait il fait cavalier 5 direct
moi je prend 2,5 du coût ni qu'aucun
marquer sa première game nico nico nico
nico nico nico nico nico nico mais voilà
faut le savoir un qui n a qu alli qui
m'ont déjà mené 4-1 mais c'est quoi
c'est la défaite à la les amis on se
fait défoncer c'est la défaite à dallas
on est déjà mené 5-1 mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça allait mais qu on se parle
avant on se dit les choses les yeux dans
les yeux on se fait défoncer on a
vraiment une équipe de charlots
c'est qui qui a perdu my bloody
valentine et on y perd contre 300 points
de plus on avait des 800 derrière elle
on a 17 cents à 6 ans n'est pas assez
nombreux les amis nos petits lots ils
sont marchés dessus parce qu'on n'est
pas assez nombreux allers thierry henry
va être en train de notre équipe est
bien sûr flow 4400 mais il ya six ans on
se fait défoncer oh là là les nex est
reparti comme la semaine dernière
pourtant on est plus nombreux mais bon
on est nul on est vraiment nul nul nul
nul
allez peut-être devant n'est pas fait
c'est devant qu'on est con et chaud mais
derrière c'est la catastrophe ada cet
impôt celi milliasseau nahla les amis
ses allers retours et guillaume cnil à
300 points de plus que moi mais je le
tiens il en sueur allez guillaume ben
natan à 300 points de moins que peu
partout
ouais moi je vais essayer de gagner la
mienne quand même j'ai dû mettre deux
heures les mecs mais moi je remplis ma
part du taf
mais bien sûr
344 plus de points que moi au deuxième
un mois j'ai que 120 points de plus au
premier un c'est pas grand chose mais tu
vas je suis cave en train de mettre en
sueur c4 bessin une boum
allez faut remonter
moi en tout cas je vis tu as tu fait mal
aux premiers mois je fais mal au premier
je suis là je suis un joueur de phares
qui guide qui guide les autres quoi on
peut jouer là on de retour je pense que
ça va non tu peux pas atteint ce qui
entre-temps tabou bull mais tu pourras
jouer le deuxième match
je pense que d'ailleurs tu peux
d'ailleurs déjà inscrit il ya neuf
attendez on va prendre on va prendre
combien là allez on se relève là on est
en train de se faire marcher dessus
u9 indices à 11 ans 12 ans on va
apprendre quoi apprendre trentin
daguin qui voilà qui est peut-être en
train de gagner sa partie c'est un
adversaire ne joue pas aller daniel moi
je sais pas du tout ce qui fait
cristiano a fait ça fait cinq minutes on
regarde même plus ma partie on s'en fout
total on a quasiment envie d'aller
regarder les autres partis tour 34 on va
prendre
allez on va taper des caps tempo on n'a
même pas réfléchi et ça c'est
complètement débile
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a fait jouer sans
réfléchir à cette cadence c'est
complètement con allez les amis que
l'esprit soit avec nous vous faut le
savoir un cas une partie gagnante ne
connaît pas son taux de ja 11,2 les mets
qui a une nouvelle parc de nouvelles
personnes qui a gagné bravo haillan à
prendre une fois un matelas d'avancé 7
jouent pas la plus partie la plus
passionnante du monde
on se donne en mais c'est bien on en
remarque un peu
allez allez allez allez moi j'avais une
tournée vite
ok je comprends plus ou moins ce qu'il
veut faire c'est pas très discret il est
pas très discret il veut faire la maj
cissé qu'érige les 5
allez je vais tenter un truc joli ballet
je prends le risque fait d'amener un
échec avec l'idée tout reprendre et un
tour prend d un roi g2 fouet fin roi
j'ai un flash 3 ah c'est beau et sur
cavaliers je vais faire dame eu de tout
le brésil en sueur le brésil en sueur
les amis il s'est pris une tactique de
chantier c'est une tactique sur les
chantiers ça s'est même pas des échecs
dames d un scellement sueur dimitri qui
a perdu on est mené 16 2 les amis on se
fait dézinguer 17,2 c'est quoi cette
catastrophe les amis 17,2 allez faut
marquer des points
moi je vais marquer madame d un sam et
en sueur faut le savoir qui va ramener
une victoire a laissé bien sûr un énième
victoire c'est génial comment cristiano
il ya réfléchi
17,3 à bout on a marqué un point aller
bravo victoire de renault renault
renault comment s'inscrire et je remets
tout mais vous pouvez pas jouer en
quinze plus vous pourrez jouer en 35
plus deux 2e tournoi vous pourrez jouer
on est en train de gagner la cristiano
on sûr j'ai mis en tel niveau de sueur
j'étais sûr que je suis sûr qu'il est
tombé dans le piège à ils sont lents les
brésiliens je te jure c'est quoi ce
premier échec en papier mâché là à côté
brésilien fait il pense à quoi qui a
valu en à me de tempo du coup y'a plus
et cavaliers g5 qui traîne et on va lui
faire tour des deux tours tomber deux
temps et comment est-ce qu'on peut dans
la sphère tour d un échange et tours et
tourbe et en même temps va encaisser en
force cris corps en sueur s'ils
regardent cette partie
krikor en sueur c'est regarde cette
partie
il ya 23
mais non mais daniel c'est bien s'il
joue pas on marque le point daniel ont
marqué les points alors à faire d'un
point 3 en premier et tour français
après j'espère qu'il va abandonner là
quand même pas ce qu'est le tour deux
mois à il veut il veut encore continuer
et bah écoute
il est venu pour il est venu poursuivre
souffrir lui c'est tout c'est tour
qualité de man et tu vas encore perdu
une pièce
cristiano est ce qui va vouloir jouer le
match retour est ce que ça t'a fait trop
mal 2250 les amis et c'est la vérité
by mam au quai mais il va pas il va pas
jouer ça quand même nom mais m'a bloqué
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
je la respecte moi quand même c'est à
dire qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
allez on a marqué on a marqué on a
marqué un but
je vais faire un tour de stade 25 à 5
mais ok j'ai marqué je suis content il
ya nicobar en caux qui a marqué aussi
deux heures a laissé bien les amis 26,6
bon c'est quand même on se fait marcher
dessus mais non on est là on est là les
amis fouet 5 alors protéger notre pions
c'est quand même notre point fort ils me
tueront des quatre mois du coup
allez les mecs là grob en une fois on va
remettre un cavalier en f3 on a fait une
telle prise des spas sallèles dames
c'est fantastique aller jeter un petit
coup de foudre des deux bîmes lplp sonné
il est tombé ton pions bîmes dame prend
à cette caisse qui a maintenant c'est la
catastrophe à la pour cristiano qui a
aidé car je protège tout c'est la
catastrophe à la pour cristiano les amis
les mâles
bîmes échec trois des huit fois 5
pouah pouah
cristiano en sueur issus les amis issus
cristiano
il est malin ça arrive de partout pour
cristiano j'aime pas si sûr wade lui tu
fais pas f3 genre tranquille histoire de
pas perdre de rien perdre quoi vous j'ai
trois échecs roi des huns je m'en fous
ouais si fait ce rallye je fais ça et
cif f5 je fais 3 quand même peut-être
bon jusqu'à l'épreuve synchro très fort
fantastique un assez bon je joue du
djembé avec ma chaise voilà ils sont ils
sont sur la la il est en sueur il avoue
je joue à la même vitesse que moi
service-volée là il se fait ce match et
la gueule
les amis on va gagner les amis cette
partie là je la gagne les a mis là grob
la grob la grotte rempli son rôle les a
mis là grob rempli son rôle des amis ont
leur marche dessus grâce à la grob la
grotte fait le boulot
c'est trop facile les amis 3,5 tempo
c'est horrible ça pour lui il a réfléchi
tellement de temps ok seul coup fourré
quatre échecs mais je vais faire fou
prend et ça va aller
non mais attendez dan des huit échecs
pim lé clou et adam la précision la
précision et alors là je peux je fais
comment est ce que je fais dames
prendront eux cette dame échec
maintenant je veux prendre ici sur les
chèques
il prend je prends sur échec et je
reprends sur échec duras toutes ces
pièces
et maintenant entourage seront à tour f3
tranquille
tranquille à comment mettre le plus vite
franges et 6 je pense roigé cette dame
province est et dames f7 mac
comment on en a gagné facile facile les
mecs
franchement en souplesse en souplesse
d'un bep vite c'était pas mal
twice est encore plus beau ok mais
surtout rev7 il l'aurait fait roi
reprend g6 mater moins vite dans le jeu
j'ai bien défoncé là j'ai bien aimé bim
bim et c'est vrai que dame b 8 c'était
sympa pour jouer sur le clouage alors
qui est ce qu'on va suivre
art riche est dans ta face que ça donne
je vais un peu les dents et on a les
noirs là on n'a pas l'air très bien mais
on menace m'attendre c'est chaud mais
ils allaient voir poule pin à tort
on va attendre sa deux secondes on
allait voir plus le pied après il ya 40
à 13 calme on se fait défoncer 4.3.3
c'est la catastrophe a bah je sais pas
ou époux le pin à tort monsieur p soit
qui a perdu
cette phase dame droit des trois lames
et moyens d'un match 7 à la machette
peut-être faire un carré à temps damages
7,4 ouais c'est peut-être pas si simple
patrick ya gagné bravo patrick alors on
nous demandait dans me2 matin ils
étaient en échec
malheureusement
bien joué d'alger 4 qui est là il ya
d'amsterdam 2 échecs fini fini
bacchus qui a perdu à bacchus
je suis écoeuré voilà dam des deux
pareils infinie richesse dans ta face
qui paiera la la cale qatar on se fait
défoncer il opine à tort
j'emprunte chercher pour le pin à tort
en fait il ya karim khan de la même
ville que - alpha zorro qui a gagné ses
deux parties mais c'est bien ça le faz
oro j'arrive pas trop et poupine à tort
ben saïd est dominateur c'est joli un
look et c'est que le début de la
deuxième mais je compte da silva pour se
réinscrire dans l'autre cadence huawei
si vous voulez jouer dans l'autre
cadence ou se réinscrire dans l'autre
cas dans ce sens il ya monsieur pesos
avec miki la grèce à mort mme millet ou
monsieur pessoa
bacchus qui à part due à la catastrophe
monsieur pessoa qui agressent à mort
alors attendez on va recadrer
l'échiquier un peu fait voir cette
agression à monsieur pessoa qui est pas
mal peut-être
ok ils agressent en tout cas c'est bien
ce qui fait monsieur p soir que je veux
pas trop donner de coups pour pas pour
pas l'aider pour qu'il puisse rester sur
le stream et c'est pas malice baffe
le charpentier qui a mis deux points
mais c'est ça le charpentier c'est bien
le charpentier
c'est bien le charpentier
on va pas aider monsieur monsieur p soir
on va regarder
renault qui met de 0,6 et bien renault a
donc passé un scanner 3d au tour suivant
il faut juste que tu quittes ce tournoi
en fait il faut inscrire directement au
tour suivant
et voilà la pointe un monsieur p soit
qui s'est pris la pointe
je voulais j'ai pas voulu le dire parce
que je voulais pas l'aider bien
évidemment mais il s'est fait pointer
avec l'enfilade et là il est fichu
dommage
dommage mais on a chopé soit mais je
pouvais pas à dire les coûts et les
tontons je pouvais pas dire que seule
idée sur le plan propose ces faux f 5 1
dassault n'a pas trop le choix
et on va voir là il ya peut-être il ya
peut-être moyen de se planter pour
l'adversaire mais il faut vraiment qu'il
fasse une grosse boulette vraiment que
l'autre fasse une grosse boulette
george est juste montrer les flèches
pour pas m'embêter monsieur pessoa messi
fait ça monsieur p soit pourrait faire
ça et du cou et du coup libéré ça mais
bon et quand bien même ça marcherait
peut-être pas mais peut-être l'autre
peut faire cette erreur là qui sait en
revanche s'il fait ça ça et ça
attention les amis
attention attention les amis j'ai senti
que mais bon ça peut même être plus
beaux genre ça ça et ça ce serait
extraordinaire
ça ce serait extraordinaire non il l'a
fait roi des huns
non non non nulle monsieur pessoa null
null null il est nul il est nul il est
nul nul nul nul nul
oh c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
monsieur pessoa c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible
or la catastrophe à là c'est la
catastrophe à die avait le piège dame
eux quatre ils auraient pu tomber dedans
achi c'était fini non non non monsieur
pessoa la pls la pls
aulas lors il était tellement proche de
l'arnaqué au nom au nom annonce est pas
possible c'est pas possible le banc ça
arrive c'est la vie mesdames c3 il
aurait dû faire dame prend tout reprend
et surtout on prend et peut-être même
tour j'ai un faux bouge ton gsa un truc
comme ça il ya décourage un peu de
partout roi je suis têtu tu actives à
fond et c'est chaud non non non pas
monsieur p soit non mais c'est pas grave
c'est la vie on s'en fout franchement on
s'en fout totalement un supérieur avant
monsieur pessoa c'est juste dommage hein
tu étais tellement pas loin ralala
race est passé proche s'est passé proche
d amy s'est passé proche
face à ça ils avaient ils avaient dame
c3 et l'utiliser d'un de kadhafi cité
partir pour pina alors guillaume les
parties qu'il peut y avoir
parce que du coup guillaume robin et
c'est guillaume robin est aussi ici donc
sélectionné pas toujours les pseudos de
chasse comme faire de vagues ils vont à
20 super g et commandé ma soirée pour
nous un jeu mais c'est la zone totale je
suis super ali merci kevin mais oui et
bien sûr ses tontons kef qui est
responsable sur réussit pas à t'inscrire
et c'est la vérité les amis boom que le
cac gagne et alpha sow qui a des ratures
maxime lagacé et bravo brisage qui a
gagné super bravo brise h alors du coup
guillaume robin et c'est quoi le pseudo
attendez j'ai des messages attendait
c'est peut-être
mon nom c'est pas c'est la catastrophe
là les amis alors donc on n'a toujours
pas guillaume robin et sign on me dit
que je peux pas jouer bas faut jouer le
deuxième tournoi un salut qui skin les
amis alors attendent également mis aux
voix basse on se voit mal octobre guy
robin et admis qu'il est pardon pardon
pardon pardon alors est ce qu'on peut
avoir le hello louis look in win win win
win win win win win in win in je vois
pas oui nous assaillent on l'a vu et il
a gagné
j'ai passé en sa partie mais il a gagné
en tout cas on sait bien qu'ils y sommes
la triche est dans ta face qu'une grosse
position d'attac attendant c'est quoi le
score puis 160 de 23 ans fait des longs
se fait dézinguer quelle catastrophe
adha
mais je perçois qu'a perdu ouais il a
gagné il a gagné alors est flou 4400 ou
j'espérais gagner mais c'est chou alors
attendons à les voir 4400 c'est hyper
chaud de trouver en fête est finie je
vais peut-être la gagne alors il est oui
il a donc et c'est chaud mais c'est vrai
qu'il est peut-être pas mal mais je n'en
dis pas plus parce que je veux pas aidé
c'est tendu on se fait démonter on se
fait démonter les amiens franchement
c'est la honte à da brat ac a perdu 2 0
ouais devant ces faits on s'est fait
marcher dessus
ouais queen mary queen queen dame météo
qui peut peut-être battre un ami ouais
c'est pas mal mais trophies on aurait
dit moyens mais la amy peut-être marquer
des points avancés on s'est vraiment
fait battre derrière un finalement mais
freddy on était un peu loin en termes
pilar qui peut c'est chaud mais il peut
peut-être faire quelque chose
alors là c'est fait ça ça ça sent quand
même assez bon mais bon on sait pas
trichet tu dans ta face aux êtres chers
dans ta face en train de défoncer bon ça
c'est la bonne nouvelle alors une
variante marrante assez sur échec
j'avais pas vu oui mon l'autre a pris
comme ça il faut être riche est dans ta
face qui devrait me défoncer je pense je
pense qu'il va le défoncer bon là il
peut faire la même tactique que moi
tchac tchac c'est un peu la même que
celle que j'ai faite à la partie
précédente voilà c'est ça nickel ni call
moi c'est fini la pièce de plus ça va
gagner tout ça je commence même par sa
caisse j'aurais pas fait mais ça gagne
parce que roy d61 sarl quoi que j'aurais
jamais joué comme ça mais bon là c'est
fini
allez c'est cool fréchette dans ta face
qui marque le point c'est cool ça fait
du bien
ce quand même complètement humiliée mais
bon au moins on gagne ou on gagne des
points on fait des perfs florent
qu'est-ce que ça la nef laurent qui a
pris florent qui est bien quand même
on n'aura fait qu'un appareil de deux
petites paires frein c'est surtout
derrière on est des joueurs à 800 condé
jours à 1200 c'est vraiment gros écart
on a queen de manioc qui va peut-être
battre un emmy en tout cas une position
pas mal
dix points d'écart entre la france et le
danemark c'est la loose et à dahouët dix
points c'est beaucoup
dix buts plutôt imagine citron chocolat
qui a perdu ouais j'y mets une pièce
pilar va mal payés non non on aura fait
les belles perfs
bon là il faut juste peut-être défendre
comme ça plus propre parce que là dessus
et à ça s'il fait juste ça plus facile
bon allez
n'a pas été très nombreux à gagner 2 0 1
on n'a pas été très nombreux à gagner
des euros annoncé clairement fait
dominer ils ont clairement des joueurs
plus forts que nous et a hissé prix là
il s'est pris la tactique up f pilar bon
ça va quand même passé mais c'est
dommage
mon marque juste prendre h et à pousser
les pions
c'est quand même assez simple juste
faire gaffe de pas de pas faire patte et
ça va gagner pense pas si malin ce qu'on
fait c'est pas si mal
on se bat bien finalement 1
mais on est juste beaucoup beaucoup
moins fort quoi c'est ça sur le papier
on est malin alors oui puis russe très
bien joué ouais je suis là me tanne
montagne encore gaspacho je rentre chez
moi demain en fait c'est mon dernier
jour de vacances
ouais donc juste poussé poussé on a pas
on n'a pas si mal joué quoi franchement
franchement c'est pas mal hein yahoo
s'inscrit au second match mais en fait
je regrette tous les liens deuxième
hachémi 5.75 +3 deuxième match qui va
pousser jusqu'au bout et non mais ça a
gagné tout seul
ça va gagner tout seul je sais pas quel
arrêt le deuxième majeur c'est quoi
c'est ses 19 heures cale est quelqu'un
qui doit moi je peux pas avoir le temps
parce que je suis déjà sur le premier
tournoi dans 36 minutes c'est à 19h20 et
on peut déjà loin mais on peut déjà
s'inscrire au deuxième tournoi et donc
ces bonnes nouvelles mais du coup je
vois plus les scores du premier match
mais on a le lien c'est le bon lien
qu'on vous a donné ce que apparemment du
second match peut encore changer oui oui
bien sûr on sait pas trop encore un
sinon le prochain match je produis en
slicks et vendredi prochain 15h en tête
on est pas mal pour le prochain match a
séparé les épinards qui a marqué le
point citron chocolat ses champs
salua le pape ou à un peu gagné départir
ça fait du bien ça fait du bien d'un
petit peu marquée des victoires il faut
marquer des victoires on voit encore un
match derrière donc
j'en reviens ce que j'ai écrit je
comprends pas de quelle partie parle en
fait tu vois le bail par an fait donc tu
pas s'il va faire je mente ci peut
prendre la frf 4 c'est n'importe quoi
mais bon j'aurais juste tellement envie
de mettre leur argent avant avec les
pions ils vont c'est débile mais je
prends juste n'importe quel coup en fait
plus ou moins tu pousses avec 4,5 après
donc bref cas direct c'est bien
donc est ce que j'aurai le prochain
match en pro chasse ligue et oui oui
j'ai bien peur que oui j'ai bien peur
que oui semaine prochaine c'est une
nouvelle fois jeté pas prévu pour jouer
mais on n'a juste pas de joueurs quoi
donc ouais on n'a même pas d'équipé pour
le moment bon on n'a même pas les moyens
de mettre quatre joueurs dans la
prochaine équipe de pro classic
tellement c'est la catastrophe avait
tellement c'est la catastrophe à la
parce que en fait ouais on a tous nos
joueurs soient gibraltar soit mike enzi
phase est la cata c'est la cata total
voit les deux équipes françaises sont
sombres les gars pour le moment mais bon
je pense qu'on va remonter
enfin nous ça va être dur là parce que
les dates sont horribles en fait il ya
que des mauvaises date pour nous pour le
moment parce que la plupart de nos
joueurs sont pas là donc il va falloir
il va falloir juste de conditions
favorables j'ai envie de dire parce que
pour le moment c'est vraiment difficile
si jamais un grand maître dans le chat
qui intéressait pour je la protège slip
vous-même n'importe quel joueur à 2400
plus n'hésitez pas à écrire mais oui
mais non c'est un complot un complot
total ray c'est un conte le total toutes
les dates ont cependant gibraltar on a
toujours à gibraltar et ça tombe le jour
avant gibraltar est le jour après donc
on a tous les jours en voyage
donc ça tombe super super super mal en
fait les dates ce genre les pires date
possible pour nous et le truc c'est que
ça affaiblit quasiment aucune des autres
équipes sauf marseille qui est aussi
affaibli du coup donc c'est vraiment le
complot contre les équipes françaises
mais un grand maître dans le chatt
n'hésitez pas mais ça m'étonnerait
mais on sait pas pourquoi pas ça lui a
en poche sa lutte on sait jamais un
super mec à 2006 on n'en sait rien
krikor qui peut pas jouer ce que
j'assure du brésil enfin d'autres
personnes qui peuvent pas jouer parce
qu'ils travaillent parce que le prochain
match tombe à 15 heures enfin bon c'est
la cata mais internationale c'est la
cata internationale dans la voir ce
qu'on peut faire
mais donc c'est un bon grand maître
pourquoi pas m'avoir ya 12 heures je
crois pas qu'il puisse jouer en tout cas
il me répond pas donc je pense que je
crois pas que tu peux qui peut jouer
qu'à partir du cette attaque et je crois
que c'est pas possible de changer
l'équipe en cours de saison non tu peux
pas changer d'équipement cours de saison
ce statut peut pas et vlad veut pas
jouer gris tube si tu connaissais ses
tarifs pour un match tu prendrais peur
mais non mais c'est juste les dates qui
sont je peux me dire qu'elles sont mal
foutu parce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils
pouvaient même et pour nous en tout cas
ça pouvait ça peut pas être des pires
date en fait y'a pas pire date que ce
qu'ils ont fait
hikaru il a déjà une équipe
[Musique]
je peux donc cette large et harris the
great choc quatre chiffres comme ça
c'est une fourchette large mais bon
comme c'est tonton kef qui paye ton kev
c'est un peu la gueule tu as quatre
chiffres pour un truc de pro che slip
qui rapporte rien vous ça fait chier
mais du coup du coup c'est dur ouais les
parties mon sens est automatiquement ça
commence dans une demi heure le prochain
match
quelqu'un qui ça lui prend trois heures
a great flu quoi se faire rémunérer à
peut-être c'est un des meilleurs joueurs
du monde gagnerait 4 chiffres sans
virgule au milieu voilà tout à fait non
puis c'est même pas sûr de gagner quoi
parce que tu as gritche meta tuerie
moyenne à 2005 donc du coup il a pas
d'équipé reach nom de city chantait ces
paroles mais non non déjà déjà duda cela
me coûte un petit peu tu vois donc bon
les fois où il joue quand il peut jouer
mais on est bien loin de ces tarifs là
même très très loin et
mais oui enfin gérard la fin ok si j'en
vois si j'envoie une grosse somme ça
sert à rien surtout pour un match de pro
classic pas je préfère un jour faire
acheter quelque chose pour moi quoi fin
j'en sais rien des conseils pour
progresser contre l'ordinateur niveau 2
demande tom sono que je sais pas et
coûte 1 j'ai du mal à j'ai du mal à te
dire fais juste les exercices sur cha
score mais progresse aux échecs en
général vous faites comment pour
rémunérer des joueurs non non c'est moi
qui finance pour la peine canoë enfin on
a quinze joueurs du cookie qui joue
rémunérer ses duda donc on n'a pas de
joueurs nous c'est juste moi en fait
mais non c'est pas du jasmin comme qui
financent plus ainsi que penses tu de
lee child dur de pour moi de te répondre
parce que je peux pas être impartial
pour cette question donc je ferai juste
pas y répondre
hélas le fou qui va tomber eric amy tu
commences à te coûter une blinde non
ouais ça me coûte un peu d'argent c'est
la vie c'est comme ça s'il a renoncé
telle chose la plus importante pour moi
tu vois je ne ferai pas des vidéos sur
youtube
du coup l'autre va ramener le roi et va
carrément f quel point je croyais tout
reprend enfin la fin est là c'est dur
pour eux queen queen madeo mais qui aura
fait une belle partie
le prochain match qui les mutants 25
minutes donc on va voir un bon temps
mort mais bon il ya du monde qui joue
n'a pas intérêt à faire une crique hors
du coude ou d'avoir énoncé la vie si je
vous mali joue malin question on n'y
peut rien c'est comme ça j'en voudrais
pas
je ne voudrais pas même si fait zéro sur
quatre questions voulu faire ça les
regarde moi j'ai bien fait un demi sur
quatre vendredi alors que si je fais 2
sur 4 ans et demi c'est très loin d'être
du vol décrit corps le match 2 2 2
vendredi justement puisqu'on parle de
krikor je pense on matthew plutôt de
woods aux ennemis tu vois il a fait
trois fêtes faut pas regarder le
résultat si tu regardes trop le résultat
comme dans tous les sports
le résultat reflète pas forcément la
performance intrinsèque des fois c'est
des fois t'es bien payé des fois t'es
mal payés et des fois tu as des roches
c'est comme ça c'est la vie
mais dans une sauce que j'avais moins de
lukla deux adversaires gagnent au phoque
si je fais un ennemi ou deux il ya
vraiment pas ce scandale
bah c'est juste normal en fait mais mais
du coup du coup je les fais pas je les
fais pas tu vas enfin genre c'est la vie
krikor il aurait dû ferment il a fait
plus ce premier round je pense qu'il
doit faire plus il a fait moins tu sais
jamais et tu vas faire un dubaï peu de
faire un macho qui vaut trois et demi
sur 4 4 sur 4 et faire d'eux tu vois
c'est possible mais tu vois qu est ce
que tu peux dire c'est comme si un
footballeur je sais pas il joue son
match de foot
il met trois frappes elle touché 3 le
poteau il mais pas de but mais si elles
sont dans l sont denses et la même tu
vois tu peux y faire
taddei champlain inscrits pour le
prochain sérieux jeu suivant en
informatique mais là c'est vraiment la
cata pour les joueurs s'ils veulent
participer il faut simplifier va écouter
créé à tchatche.com tu vois je suis pas
super webmaster de check point comme
donc tu agis peu j'y peux rien enfin tu
es le premier à avoir un souci donc du
coup c'est pas forcément super pratique
mais ce n'est pas non plus insurmontable
kanak et puis c'était après un fois à
vendredi t'auras pas peur de gagner tu
aller manger un objet parce qu'ils n'ont
pas peur de gagner tu vas mais j'étais
en vacances en plus et puis plus voilà
tête des fois t'es bien payé des fois
t'es mal payé tu vois c'est comme ça
c'est le sport
c'est comme ça c'est comme ça enfin
question y faire des fois ça se passe
bien mieux que ça devrait enfin je sais
pas dans les pièces points comme
beaucoup mieux bien évidemment même
super impartial il ya quand même pas
photo mais bon des curieux du contenu du
truc pro pour progresser c'est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus précis quoi
n'essayez pas teigneux et que je ne
connais pas sérieux je reviens jamais
mais enfin oui mes joueurs quand bien
même un comme tu veux un vague de femmes
moi c'est un événement à ne plus jamais
revenir enfin ne revient plus fort mais
j'y peux rien enfin mais je crois que
les noirs le mec avec les noirs qu'elle
n'est pas super fort
bah non mais bon c'est un tueur mais j'y
peux rien faire un pays fondamentalement
je m'en fous un petit peu aussi quoi
bon et ce qui va se faire mater ou pas
faut faire gaffe la main et menace de
maths en un lien intime oh je sais que
ma bière par jour ça s'enchaîne souche
bon et ce qui va réussir à le faire
tomber ou pas bon qu'il envoie le pion
avec qui il espère qu'ils aient pas de
matin mais faire a5 a6 a7 a8 et puis
voir un mais bon si l'autre je pense
menace kf2 matelas quand même mais bon
peut-être fait tour à 3 ouais mais bon
il y aura tour ici et x 4 tu tiens
comment il a fini par tomber
mais il était malade il était mal barré
bon je connais pas le match du pool au
score du premier match du coup mais je
pense qu'on s'est fait laminer j'ai même
pas envie d'aller voir
bon allez faut s'inscrire pour le
deuxième match
alors je vais mettre les liens tonné
tout le lien et le deuxième match du
coup le lien c'est celui là
raiffeisen le truc c'est que ça tu
participes à un truc en club 1 donc tu
es obligé de s'inscrire au club france
pour pourra jouer avec le club france
est quand même assez logique
du coup ce qui est quand même pas très
dur puisque sa demande un clic et c'est
gratuit en plus donc
et après vous allez trouver noix et les
url à l'isi sont c'est quand même pas ce
pas insurmontable c'est loin d'être
insurmontable pas il me semble après
j'en sais rien peut-être c'est moi qui
qu'ils aient l'impression que c'est
facile et qu'en fait c'est très
difficile mais j'ai quand même
l'impression que c'est assez simple 30
82 32 le score s est pas pas étonnant
pas étonnant et l'on là on doit attendre
donc encore une vingtaine de minutes bon
bah écoute et chocolat qui tient et qui
va empêcher la fortwo nadeau de jouer le
match
ils n'auront pas le temps de s'inscrire
pour le prochain match c'est génial les
pro b 4 peut-être ya peut-être pu
prendre des cadres des quatre tentes et
b3 et pousser son pion adam bon ça ne
marchait pas mais aurait pu tenter
allez on est partis fortune instruction
chocolat allez on rejoue la même
ouverture que tout à l'heure contre
contre tonine aux rites voir si ça passe
un peu un peu risqué là comme je vois
1,2055 +3 un poil risque à l'eau mais on
va voir le gambit genish on va voir on
dit qu'on lui et met 400 points de plus
allez faut pas faire faut pas faire les
enfants on est courageux on se bat
regardez moi j'envoie des pions moi je
vous de la merde total mais je suis là
j'ai envoyé un pion dans le désert et
j'envoie le jeu j'envoie le beau jeu je
suis là je suis à fond j'ai mis mes
pions au centre à l'est le 4 janv vois
ça s'est très mal joué je reprends du
cavale
j'ai absolument n'importe quoi mais joue
dans l'esprit aph
j'ai envoyé un pion mais je me développe
un jeu
j'ai mes flèches quoi germain mitroglou
on est là germain mitroglou on est là on
va prendre ici on va faire le petit rock
tranquille on a germain ni troubles ou
bien placé est ce qu'il va pouvoir
résister à cette aux attaquants
marseillais
vous êtes une petite arrivée d'un
balotelli qui va venir
renforcer tout ça je mettrai peut-être
un nom la jouer tranquille va faire
qu'on va faire alors là je tremble on va
faire ses 6 30 il protège on est bien
tranquillement 3 on va faire non damas 5
on peut pas quitter sète on peut pas
d'âme 7 on peut pas d'âme f6 on peut là
mais ça ne pouvait pas les cavaliers f5
damas cinq équipes b 3 dha même s'ils
sont les diagonales par rapport aux
cavale donc on est tranquille du coup on
peut faire qui a aidé cette maintenant
bloqué à la rigueur il fait fou g5 ont
fait à manger ici sans avoir à faire
qu'à rio 5 lycées 4 bon ok on était
complètement foutu on est toujours mal
mais bon on se place un peu calé cinq
essais 4 ça peut ça peut être sympa
tâche mon a sorti nos pièces manquantes
à un peu sous pression
on le met un peu sous pression les mecs
aller aux faucons marca les mecs info
tous appliquer là on est allé on est
déjà mené 1 0 ils ont déjà marqué un
premier but je sais pas où mais ils ont
déjà marqué le premier but fouet f4 ok
j'ai envie de commencer par tours 8
même si c'est pas indispensable et faire
qui avait b6 maintenant je sais lectoure
et 8 ch contrôle quelques cas ce qui
pourrait être importante à un moment
donné case trois ans r il fait que 4
quand même
riquet ces quatre thèmes pro menaces
qu'elles ne gagnent saddam en un an le
mais on le met on le met sous pression
je sens et sur d'amd ont fait kébé 2 qui
a aidé 3 on est des génies quoi je
patients à quel point c'est bon mais bon
tente en tout cas on le met sous
pression autant qu'il fasse dame ces
deux du coup d'année en qui on va faire
sans rajout et tempo
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on même à l'otan
et je pense que s'il fait le singe
czekaj prend d un pion prend qui est
prend ces trois qui est français cissé
qui a eu deux échecs et je vais
reprendre fkt je pense que ça peut
peut-être aller sous quelques jours et
peut-être fou prend la main au kef et
damages 5
on va dire qui menacerait à revenir en
d3 avec lecavalier
ok peut-être il veut ça intermédiaire
mais j'ai dame prend un f2p y prendre ok
il fait 5
reste que c'est fort ça comme
intermédiaire qu'elle se faire [ __ ] en
d4
il prend f6 je prends f2 et je reprends
le 1 mai tête je me fais maths et dans
l'enchaînement je peux pas prendre
cinquante ans ait su prendre des 4 il
prend là je prends la sueur échec qui
vient là et je vais me faire contre
mater sur cases noires sache peut pas
prendre f4 il prend f4 et je prends un
f4 et il peut pas prendre ces six bon je
vais faire ça je prends la f4 je vais
jouer ce que je voulais jouer en premier
mais j'ai voulu eux je voulais faire un
peu de festivals mais du coup là je
récupère le pion je mets des quatre sous
pression ça sous pression ça sous
pression sommes à l'air d'aller pas trop
mal
alors il veut bien évidemment échanger
les dames on les connaît un on les
connaît ok je pense pas que je puisse
trop éviter je vais faire un petit tour
ses huit bêtes m'en fous j'ai quatre
tours c'est cette ce pas si clair mais
bon on partait de loin donc c'est pas
mal on partait de loin qui est fait à 4
j'ai quand même joué pour ses sets ça
peut me servir un moment donné de
contrôle à un peu ça pour le moment je
veux pas tout recettes mais je veux
peut-être 6 pouces faire foi satc 5
pour le moment il faut prendre des
cartes je veux pas parce qu'il reprend
là c'est chiant on c'est reparti je sais
pas du tout d'où venait le problème mais
du coup c'est un peu chaud parce que
j'ai pas pu trop calculer pendant
quelques coups là et donc je me suis mis
mal je met le roi
j'aime pas trop ma position là
quel peut-être faire ça et sur quels
points f7 pour preuve cette prise à ce
stade du ray x 6 échecs et tour g1 maths
mais bon je suis pas fan de la position
quand même on est menés 9 2-9 22-29
pardon voit donc bizarre comme bugs sont
en fait j'ai pas j'ai pas trop buggé
je voyais toujours le live et ou pas
georges est toujours le chat et où le
tout le tralala
ok donc il vient là on va faire de toute
façon un échec
qu'est ce qu'un assez courageux là ce
qui est en train de faire je faire fois
ci fait qu'il prend je ferais 3g cette
tour b sat et j'essaie d'aller mater et
sinon je tenterai peut-être un petit fou
et 3 je vais tenter un petit fou ou
trois comme ça je lui coupe je lui coupe
le pion et je veux faire un truc genre
échec ou food étroit juste bêtement
foulée 3 pouces et de maths
ça m'a l'air assez sympa comme positions
sont rois beaucoup plus faible que le
lien finalement il s'est pris la contre
attaque à da toni droid aux et il est
mal il est mal il est même très mal mal
autant mal de partout même en 2005 aussi
en blitz un peu il a fait aussi ce allez
on va pas réfléchir bas les menaces
émanant d'un ci prend 3 on va reprendre
à tempo ça me permet de gagner un peu de
temps et de laisser mal qu'il évite tous
les matins je laisse pousser deux
matches rappelle parce que j'ai un four
3 alors il lévite il évite le mat
ok pas mal joué je vais continuer à
pousser du coup je veux créer une menace
de type tour échec
on va la faire justement suroît ici on
fera tout reproche de suite tour
prochain et suroît ici on fera un pion
pouces allan sirois ici on n'aura même
pas deux échecs et tour croire et donc
on allait le maté allez une petite
grotte de nouveau on lui a fait mal hein
on lui a fait très très mal tony tony
montana tony montana en sueur aller le
gambit dame a les joues une slave ma
forme à green slavin une slave contre la
drogue nous jouer un instant nos vols
bizarre paysage qui a perdu qui me
désole les raye ça craint c'est la
défaite à la
brisage qui a perdu c'est peut-être le
pion un jour écouter la partie c'est
complètement n'importe quoi donc on va
continuer dans l'esprit un tueur fou bk
je veux juste faire froid et faim fait
trois très bien placé dans la grand bain
en f1 alors là c'est un bordel monstre
c'était peut-être bien joué il agit rien
j'ai rien vraiment un
on est mal je tente le truc le plus con
du monde je prends là et je prends des
cinq même f 5 mois peut-être même un f5
mais il va prendre 5 je prends de g5
annoncé pour rien on va prendre des cinq
mais c'est pourri tellement pourri de
chez pourri on est mal mal mal 5.5 ces
raids vont apprendre des cinq céret
dossier bon il prend on prend il prend
on va prendre il va apprendre à
apprendre
alors on a quoi à l'heure actuelle il a
on a deux pions à on a quand même deux
pions en coûte qu'avait lieu 4 et c'est
moche quand même
on va faire grand roc va faire grand
roque quai on essaye de mettre un peu
nos pièces en jeu c'est fou aussi je
pensais la catastrophe a bloqué et rock
ok ok c'était je peux peut-être est-ce
que je fais tout rejet un faux calcul un
petit peu mais je vais tout soissons
commencer par tour g1
quelle menace prise au quai est ici et
ce que je peut théoriquement avoir un
truc ce que j'ai un truc genre fou prend
prises et d'amd 8 met sa menace trop
rien il y aura juste vous bougez
malheureusement
malheureusement il y aura juste
faubourgs enfin il ya un truc là je
réussis pas à créer une menace je peux
pas créé de menaces je veux pas faire le
quart d'une menace
qui est peut-être la meilleure chance
c'est prendre la sphère damas trois les
pions prend 17 et je pense que au moins
je gagne quand même un pion de plus pas
je gagne je il a quoi et j'ai trois
pions pour la pièce et même si c'est un
peu chaud mais il faut aussi sam 7 quoi
ça va infosys comprends mais cette dame
cette web ont peut-être que si ben non
c'est très mauvais mais puisque à 3,8 à
la fin il y aura 8 à la fin 8 à la fin
qui est bon il fait fou et 5 c'est
encore une autre manière de jouer qui je
vais prendre là de toute façon
il n'y a pas de truc je crois gravissime
ok
quel jeu joue un coup un peu bizarre je
faire trois genres je passe mon tour en
jean pêche les trucs avait que trois
pour mme attaqué le roi je veux faire
roi bien et je laisse je laisse devoir
construire quelque chose et
éventuellement surtout réduite tête je
veux faire dame prend à cette
bizarrement et du coup ça me ferait
quand même déjà captions ça devient de
plus en plus chaud après et pour le
moment 23 c'est pas mal je laisse
trouver quelque chose est sûre dams et
3b 1 dans le premier set j'aurais dams
est roi et où reprend 17 g dames
première fuite
pour le moment ça tient
pas si simple pour tony tony montana
c'est un peu qui a fait tout 27 hockey
bras je dois faire dame prend à cette
façon ok il des tours prend 17 d'un
premier set
issou avec le match là-bas est très
important de rejouer trois ça lui permet
de pas avoir deux de trucs et peut-être
bizarrement je veux faire tourner cinq
avec les blancs jusqu'où de fouine ok
j'ai réussi à [ __ ] le bordel
j'ai réussi à [ __ ] la merde et à
compliquer le truc peut être faut juste
qu'il fasse un coup avec l'option h
et ça va très bien pour lui
je vais peut-être tour des cinq ans même
rapidement pour tenter le les états
américains et l'état d'un des états
d'amérique sont comme les états
d'amérique ça allait commander la
situation n'allait marrant cette partie
non c'est pas moi elle me fait marrer
mais après peut-être que moi qui la
trouvent rollin stone hirohito tony
montana ah bon espagnol as le portugais
ch d'être peut-être show là pour lui
pour toni ritter désaturation de micro
est le micro qui sature peut-être un peu
je mette un peu moins fort ça moins
saturé il a fait bouger 6 à mâlain
peut-être ma langue ce lynx mâle et on
en voit quand même tour des 5
pour preuve est celle d'un premier set
je crois quelle folie dams et saintes
je veux juste jouer roi bien là dessus
comme ça je me barre un peu qui met sa
main pression' pas trop ce que je fais
dans des 4 je protège b2
on en croit g8 je peux pas faire de
provocation dame prend des deux matches
je t'ai vu un truc comme h4 évite une
nouvelle fois pour preuve de lecouls qui
m'inquiétait
ok c'est le cookie m'inquiéter parce que
maintenant sur h5 qui prend prends je
sais pas manqué de faire b3
qu'un peu saignant mais qui n'est
peut-être pas si mauvais que ça ça c'est
très pénible
on obligé de partir là dedans mais on
est foutu au kenya dams est encore adam
8,6 à tour f8
mais on serait d'en prendre quatre à huy
pourra bouger le roi ok c'est foutu ben
et 8 seul coup du coup dommage qu'ils
aient trois secondes de de rajouts
comment on a réussi à faire nul quand
même vous pouvez peut-être courir avec
la tour eiffe mais il n'a pas osé on a
sauvé la nulle pas mal pas si mal bon on
va enchaîner avec le troisième tournoi
commence dans dix minutes
bon ça commence assez bientôt du coup je
suis un peu déçu j'aurais peut-être pu
la gagner mais ok on a quand même pas
mal arnaque et on partait avec une pièce
de moins dernier tournage et bientôt
vous récupérez lien on va juste injuste
regarder comment ça se finit dommage on
s'est bien battu
bah
bon à la bonne nouvelle c'est que duda
va jouer ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle on va enfin
une bonne nouvelle dans ce dans ce live
par le ok du coup on joue le titre les
bons c'est cool
c'était chaud donc du coup on n'a que
quatre joueurs qui peuvent jouer mais on
peut tout jouer
du coup on joue le titre les amis de
nouveau je vais accepter tous les gens
qui m'ont et en amis alors le prochain
tournoi je suis content enfin une bonne
nouvelle
enfin une bonne nouvelle
leurs enfants une bonne nouvelle des
amis
enfin une bonne nouvelle ah ça fait
plaisir ça fait plaisir
guillaume qui avait eu droit qu'à 300
points depuis c'est super alors brisage
4 nuls c'est bien brisage bien jouer
alors je en train de rechercher le le
truc bien joué à jj alex est le lien
ouais il ya un dernier match en 2 + 1 et
dans deux semaines y aura un nouveau
match ce sera les vendredi après midi
mais je crois que les brésiliens les
portugais brésilien là c'est les plus
forts
du coup ça devrait mieux se passer pour
le prochain match et on recommence dans
5 minutes le prochain je m'inscris à
l'ambulatoire tête nos chances la compo
de l'équipe alors bas du cou duda paul
beltaine arroux témoin
donc ça va du coup on est on joue le
titre les amis d'un moment on a une
compo correct c'est pas la compo max
mais on a une compo que c'est juste qu'à
un moment donné on pensait pas disons
que si seb pouvez jouer à la place de
duda c'était bonne nouvelle parce que
c'était le meilleur joueur qu'on pouvait
espérer avoir cette joie et même si ça
joue bien aux échecs et tout ça a manqué
par rapport à duda on peut aucun d'entre
nous ne peut se comparer il a quand même
été vice champion du monde de blitz donc
bon c'est pas estrie vrai bien sûr que
je trie mes oies le walk on the wild
bien sûr bien sûr que le stream ray
mais n'oubliez pas vous et follow la
chaîne chasse comme fr s'est pas encore
le cas 1 on a un candidat m grobet sq
qui joue avec nous on n'est pas très
fort non plus pour le dernier match
ça démarre dans cinq minutes
donc on va bientôt démarrer
mais enfin une bonne nouvelle je suis
content c'est je suis très heureux bon
allez encore en quatre minutes
on va voir
bonsoir acide misa qui vient de rentrer
du taf
donc je pense que je jouerai un peu le
l'aréna ce soir n'est en mode
tranquillou et puis on verra ce que ça
donne mais je la jouerai peut-être pas
tout le long je commencerai puis on
verra bien ce que ça donne et c'est
tellement bonne nouvelle à combien de
recevoir les mecs vous n'imaginez même
pas parce que ces matches très
importants leur produit à 6h vendredi
prochain très important pourquoi parce
que y'a plein de points à prendre il ya
des points match aller pour les points
partie et si tu mets pas manquer la même
si on rate notre truc ce qui est
possible on peut faire de la merde
honnêtement on peut faire de la merde
moi sur 7 je peux très bien faire de
minimes 3 tout à fait possible et la
route peut faire de la mer peut faire de
la merde et jean-christophe peut faire
de la merde mais je viens on va pas
finir on peut même finir dernier mais en
fait tu mets une équipe genre paulo
premier parce que là c'est les premiers
que vous compte les premiers haruto 2
les 2 contre les deux même si on a c'est
beau 3 admettons et moi aux quatre en
fait j'ai fait d'avoir duda déjà ta
paulo de harut aux trois ont déjà tu des
cales d'un donc ça c'est bien
on va dire que la route est celle ci est
à peu près le même niveau donc aux trois
ça changerait pas grand chose mais je
pense paul fort car août surtout en
rapide et du coup aux deux c'est bien
mieux qu un et du coup duda beaucoup
plus fort que paul donc c'est quand même
énorme différence mêmes même si on fait
pas un super truc au moins on sera pas
on sera pas au fond quoi ok c'est pas
notre équipe la plus forte c'est pas
notre compo la plus forte plus forte
mais c'est une compo descente quoi au
moins ce qu'en réalité on pourrait avoir
on pourrait avoir
duda lagarde
paul et moi dans la leçon et duda
lagarde paul et moi on est vraiment bien
c'est notre consommation avec non duda
paul et non duda ça passe pas mais duda
fab 12 et fab
paul et moi ça passe ou tout à la garde
d des mois mais peut-être qu'avec fable
à la place de la route ça ça passe aussi
et c'est peut-être encore plus fort mais
mais du coup ça va être bien qu'ils ont
gagné 4 tu as acheté le maillot de
cannes entre autres chez sygma en fait
j'ai mes propres maillot si tu veux
guillaume donc je mets mon propre
maillot que j'ai fait moi-même en fait
et non sera pas en même temps que
l'aréna youtube parce que ce sera à 15
heures la prochaine ligue ballon va
avoir et on essaie de les battre en
bullet les mecs
non mais du coup on n'a pas l'équipe max
max on a une équipe très décente en fait
donc donc forcément
forcément ça fait la diff surtout que
duda il peut il peut te faire 5 sur 7 kw
à 5 sur 7 6 sur 7 il peut faire au
premier vingt
ça peut aller quoi
fabre de fabrique toujours pas je sais
pas c'est peut-être mon ordi qui en
sueur parce que le lien le lien il
marche pour tout le monde un faible de
fab
c'est l'impression que tu t'en es pris à
tchatche.com et tu as pont comme s'en
prend à toi quoi bon aller ça va faire
deux parties de bullet je fais le ch a
fait très attention
ah ouais chez le chat mais bon c'est pas
un lavage ici fait à 5 plus de mains du
coup il faut faire le deux puces intel
mardan une minute attention en plus
c'est même dans tournoi je pense est
hyper facile à trouver à laisser partir
leurs origines grob bon allez on va
pousser à fond il y en a marre bon je
veux absolument n'importe quoi c'est
génial
alors est-ce qu'on peut s'enfermer notre
propre fous ont fait ces quatre ans le
laisse prendre ont fait tour b 1 on se
bat c'est quand même sacrément n'importe
quoi là ce que je suis en train de jouer
c'est génial c'est formidable c'est
formidable
bref un bien évidemment le roi de la
grob pourra très bien le bassin est fin
et là ils ont sur ok à la rigueur je
vous dis on va prendre une fois on va
faire cavalier n'assure car hélas on a
peut-être cavaliers prend et surtout
reprend m 2 qui a rallié prend il n'ya
pas cavalier 3 maths parce que le fou
couvre au moins ça tient pour le moment
ça tient par est-ce que ça va tenir
longtemps j'en sais rien mais pour le
moment ça tient plutôt bien c'est assez
gros basque comme position c'est
grotesque et grobet ce cas la fois mais
ça tient d'un me cinq essais 4 ok qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est grotesque et
grotesque
bon allez j'en vois je fais bim
il fait bim et je fais bim gens voient
en tout cas on est mieux au temps et il
ya le front des six qui traîne à la caf
et enfin sur kg 4 mai un tracas voyage
de maths ce qu'il a peut-être raté tout
à l'heure peut-être qu'ils avaient
quadrillé g4 quelques quoi bon ici
peut-être kg cas très fort et sur kai
provokat il y avait un cavalier h deux
matches j'espère vous avez le temps de
le voir parce que là ça m'a l'air d'être
sympa tosh pour moi alors ils menacent
maths en un ce que je peux faire un truc
fort ou pas j'ai bien envie de garder
les dames sur l'échiquier parce que
c'est dans l'esprit mais je pense qu
objectivement je dois échanger et faire
flouer f3 au moins je couvre bien ça
j'avais pas vu ça j'ai raté
s'agira t malheureusement là il ya
cavaliers ici un peu pénible mais je
peux faire cavalier 3 je crois qu'il
vente assez chiante cavani ici kf3 tour
pro f 3 pions prend qui est des deux
rois eu deux fous pranger 2 1 et je
pourrai jouer roi prend des deux ça ira
donc à f3 pour éviter kg 3 maths et
cavaliers des deux en même temps s'il
fait fou pranger de faut que je reprenne
du roi je crois ok ça j'ai calculé
bien évidemment qui a aidé de roy 2 ça
j'ai vu cavaliers là j'ai vu aussi et du
coup vous prend h3 ok mais je manque le
roi ok je montre le roi ok je manque le
roi ok je montre le roi ok je blinde
je m'en fous le roi j'ai monté le roi
font alors maintenant je peux faire h
d'affaires cavaliers prends je fais
retour h1 je vais prendre là 6 mais
c'est peut-être pas terrible
malheureusement c'est pas terrible je
faire bref 6
bref cette langue et mirwais 1 qui
menace sa et j'encaisse laisse
j'encaisse et j'encaisse et j'encaisse
ya ya ya
j'ai encaissé je les encaisser la grotte
dans ta gueule j'ai encaissé
j'ai encaissé c'est pas terrible à ce
que je fais mais mons parages et
l'encaissé encore gelé encaissé à fond
et là je sens au niveau de sueur qui
remonte de fonder s'ils sont absolument
rien à faire à ya peut-être qui est des
cinq as mince ok il voit pas quel
dessein que je pense à gagner la dame
j'ai oublié qu'après à trois ça devenait
une menace
je suis heureux de l'avoir encaissés
alors ici est ce que madame ait perdu
[Musique]
ballon s'en fout total à l'est
allez les tontons donc pas les
l'encaissé peut-être je le sens sueur ok
mais là là et ce qu'ils au courant que
l'esprit est au dessus de tous ces cinq
échecs reprise n'y a rien
mon objet de faire ça pour le moment
contraint et forcé en fer g5 ce que s'il
fait toujours là si on prend c'est un
coût qui est ça pourrait être un coup
mais il avoue prend quand même
malheureusement sinon ça aurait pu être
un couteau reprend h7 qui on prend les
tours prend c'est un peu dangereux pour
lui
[Musique]
mais bon d'un autre côté surtout reprend
faut qu'il le voit le truc hockey fait
ça
qui on va tenter ça quand on envoie tout
cas il prend qui on prend 1,4 t il prend
pas quelle folie avec et f5
ok il prend kessy je prends la dame il
bouge le cavalier là et j'ai rien de
plus ce qu'on va prendre comme ça je
suis short je suis nigel a peut-être g3
et kg 4 ça peut être sympa ça j'ai
dommage que j'ai pas vu tempo parce que
je suis un peu nigel cki nigel short
maintenant bîmes d'un point bout
la tactique à dà lat actifs icade à boom
bah c'est pas mal ça bein ouai j'ai
senti qu'il allait craquer il a pas tenu
le rythme tonye tonye or c'était trop
tactique
bîmes coup droit revers papa
voilà à guillaume qui a gagné 2-0 moi
aussi j'ai mis 2 0 il était nul ouais
c'est cool cool par verre non mais le
pied jada à la fin bill mais surtout
c'est génial quand il perd hyper tout
quoi part il a craqué
ça va
ça va ça on a assuré on a assuré donc
n'hésitez pas à flots la chaîne en est
le petit choeur ces coûts le brésil le
brésil en sueur mais bon se refait
défoncé 1 dans le match on a repris à 77
à 27
alors qu'ils avaient alloué être baba
qui étaient là moi peut-être plus de
chance la semaine prochaine pendant deux
semaines du coup on s'est bien battu
nancy reda mais ce qui peut il aller
blanc a annoncé la catastrophe annoncée
à prendre sur échec qui est le cas pas
pris sur échec mairie va faire
maintenant
ok il n'a pas fait d'amener deux échecs
étonnant il a ciré d'amanvi annonce
dommage le score est lourd 1
le score est très lourd les amis 82 29
ans qui a fait 3 3 c'est pas mal hein
c'est pas mal moi je fais comme je fais
cinq et demi sur six je suis là j'ai mis
mes points j'ai mis mes points mais
d'amis alouettes barak a mis ses points
aussi est guillaume qui a souffert
citron chocolat qui a souffert est vrai
c'est en milieu de tableau on avait
moins de points et l'autre par tous
c'était devant que ça allait non mais
écoutez
est ce que si je fais l'aréna la dent
dans 50 minutes vous êtes chauds
poursuivre aurait peut-être commence il
ya du monde je la joue et puis si a pas
grand monde
je quitterais du coup on va voir je vais
mettre le lien et puis je vous promets
pas de la jouer on va voir mais
peut-être joue le début puis on la joue
en mode relax
écoutez merci à tous d'avoir suivi
n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit follow
sur la chaîne ça fait toujours plein et
ce soir d'annoncer une petite détente en
lisant le chat et machins et on se fait
plaise à l'est à tout à l'heure les mecs
probablement